hey 42 here if you're anything like me
you probably spend your days pondering
profound questions like
do eyebrows count as facial hair and
if we only ever use bath towels when
we're clean why do we need to wash them
but some people let's call them
scientists
are at this very moment engaged with
even bigger questions than
can crop circles be square some of these
cosmic conundrums include
what is the universe made of why does
mata exist
and what's going on in the center of the
sun
solving these puzzles seems to depend on
us understanding something even more
mysterious
than the mysteries themselves the
neutrino
apart from sounding like a brand of
breakfast cereal neutrinos are the
current darlings of the physics world
attracting hundreds of millions of
dollars in research investment
they are also amongst the tiniest and
most abundant particles
in the universe you wouldn't know it
though
because you can't see them and not just
because they're even smaller
than your dad's twitter following
they're literally
invisible to understand why we need to
take a quick refresher course
on the four fundamental forces of nature
governing
everything that happens in the universe
gravity
electromagnetism the weak nuclear force
and the strong nuclear force you'll
hopefully be familiar with gravity it's
the one that keeps the earth in orbit
around the sun
and stops you from drifting off into
space when you fart
it exists between any objects that have
mass or energy
unlike the other three gravity isn't a
force
at all but the curving of space-time
which causes objects to deviate from a
straight path
electromagnetism is the physical
interaction between
electrically charged particles it's what
keeps atoms from falling apart
and talking about their feelings and it
relies on the exchange of photons which
are also the particle components of
light
the weak nuclear force is responsible
for particle decay
which happens when one type of subatomic
particle
has an identity crisis and changes into
another
this force plays a big role in the
nuclear fusion that powers the sun
and by implication or life on earth
finally the strong nuclear force is as
the name
implies really strong in fact it's 6 000
trillion trillion trillion times
stronger than gravity
but it operates at a quantum level
binding the fundamental particles of
matter together
i have to say it's reassuring to know
someone's taking care of that
neutrinos are immune to the strong force
and electromagnetism
which means they don't react with light
literally can't be seen and are only
affected
by the weak force and gravity
but since they have almost zero mass
even
gravity hardly touches them now you
might be wondering just how we know that
these unimaginably tiny not to mention
invisible
little buggers even exist and the truth
is we didn't until relatively recently
in the 1930s the scientific community
was puzzling over a phenomenon known as
beta decay
a process in which an atom's nucleus
spontaneously
emits an electron the problem was
the behavior of the various particles at
play in beta decay
didn't seem to make sense apparently
violating the laws
of the conservation of both energy and
momentum
the world's finest minds were stumped
that is until physicist wolfgang paoli
came along
and postulated that a previously unknown
particle
might be involved to balance the
mathematical books
the neutrino even then it still took
another 26
years until we were actually able to
detect one directly
which is funny really when you consider
that every second
about 50 trillion neutrinos from the sun
pass through our bodies not into our
bodies
literally straight through and then they
travel
all the way through the earth and on
with their journey to
god alone knows where when you're a
neutrino
mata simply doesn't matter it's enough
to leave you feeling a bit
violated they could at least buy dinner
first
or those neutrinos could buy you the
next best thing
a premium membership to today's sponsor
blinkist
it probably wouldn't surprise you if i
told you there's little i love
more than reading nonfiction books but
these days
i rarely get the time i'm sure you're in
the same boat
well i recently discovered blinkist
instead of spending a few days
reading a whole book i can listen to all
the best bits from over 3
000 non-fiction books in only 15 minutes
that's a pretty nifty idea if you ask me
i've been trying out blinkist and it's
been a game changer for my daily routine
i listen to a blink whilst i'm having
breakfast
every morning and by the time i drunk my
last sip of coffee
i've learned new fascinating knowledge
and amusings from the world's best
authors and thinkers
and if you want to dive a little deeper
premium members get a whopping 65
of full-length audio books that you can
listen to
right in the blinkist app you can use
blinkers to save
time and money and learn new things
faster than ever before
personally i'd recommend the silk roads
by peter frankopan
he doesn't just inform you about ancient
civilizations on their trade
he tells you why it's important too the
first 100 people to visit my unique link
below
are going to get unlimited access for
one week to try it out
completely free and you can cancel at
any time
but if you just can't get enough then
through my link
you'll also get 25 off if you want the
full membership
these subatomic ghosts are so difficult
to influence
that if you were to fire a neutrino into
lead
it would travel for roughly two years at
almost the speed of light
before it came to a stop that's about
19 trillion kilometers of lead
by contrast it only takes about 10
centimeters
to stop most of the radiation from a
nuclear holocaust
and the seemingly random bugs that cause
your computer to crash
many are caused by neutrinos interacting
with the roughly 70 atoms wide
transistors in your computer's processor
and memory except for windows blue
screen of death
that's just shoddy programming neutrinos
pose such a threat to reliable computing
that mission critical data center
servers use error correcting
ecc memory which patches the data
corruption
caused by neutrinos in real time
by now you might be thinking who cares
so what if there are more neutrinos in
the universe than pretty much anything
else
beyond occasionally interrupting my
counter-strike sessions
they're harmless totally neutral and
seem to be minding their own business
they're basically the switzerland of
quantum reality
true but these elusive particles may
just be able to provide us with the
answer to
one of the biggest questions in science
why the hell do we exist
unless you're one of those people who
believes the world was created by the
flying spaghetti monster
if you've been watching my videos lately
you'll know that is a real religion
sort of then you're probably on board
with the idea that the universe
was born with the big bang about 13.8
billion years ago
what existed just before the big bang
remains a topic for
arm wrestling contests at cosmology
conferences
but scientists reckon they have a pretty
good understanding
of what happened just afterwards
mata and antimatter began to spread
throughout the infant
universe initiating a phase colloquially
called
the hot big bang and it's still going on
today
causing the steady expansion of space
mata of course is all around you you can
give it to your mum for christmas
in the form of a nice potted plant you
can tell us about your childhood trauma
in the form of a psychiatrist mata is
nothing if not
varied it's defined as any substance
that has mass
and takes up space at a subatomic level
mata is made up of particles like
electrons and protons
that are the building blocks of physical
reality
for each of these particles there are
anti-particles
identical opposites that have opposite
physical charges
but have the same mass and behave in the
same way
at least according to current theories
antimatter
is matter made up of these
anti-particles
think of it like mata's evil twin if
mata
and antimatter collide they annihilate
each other
releasing pure energy you might have
noticed
there's not a lot of that going on most
of the time and that's because the
universe is made up
almost entirely of normal matter with
very little antimatter to annihilate
to be honest i feel okay about that but
apparently this
asymmetry of mata and antimatter in the
visible universe
is one of the greatest unsolved
mysteries in physics
and that's why our little friend the
neutrino
is so hot right now but more on that in
a moment
it's important not to mistake antimatter
for dark matter
the bizarre stuff that makes up about 85
of the total mass in the universe
and about 27 of all energy and mass
if you're looking for some truly
illuminating information on dark matter
then check out my video on the subject
but in a nutshell
this stuff offers an explanation for the
excess gravity that magically seems to
be holding galaxies together
because physicists are really good with
words
dark matter is exactly what it says on
the tin
dark it does not absorb emit
or reflect light so we can't see it
there could be dark matter skinny
dipping next to you right now
and you wouldn't even know it the truth
is nobody's completely sure
what dark matter actually is
but further proving their flair for
wordplay
astrophysicists have come up with a few
candidates including
machos wimps and gimps
not to be confused with the s m role
play game of the same name
machos are massive astrophysical compact
halo objects
basically bloody big blobs of normal
matter
like stars that are just so dim we can't
see them
gimps or gravitationally interacting
massive particles
are purely gravitational field
singularities of space-time
that react to gravity alone wimps
are weakly interacting massive particles
hypothetical elementary particles that
are really heavy but only react to
gravity
and the weak nuclear force making them
invisible
neutrinos can't be wimps because they
have tattoos
and open beer bottles with their teeth
and we also don't think they're heavy
enough to account for all the dark
matter in the universe
so why are astronomers cosmologists
astrophysicists
and other party animals so obsessed with
them
because they may hold the answer to the
mata
antimatter asymmetry problem we talked
about earlier
which is a really big deal if your day
job is unlocking the secrets to the
origins of the universe
the riddle goes something like this the
big bang
should have created equal amounts of
mata
and antimatter which should then
have annihilated each other in one big
orgy of cancel culture
but they didn't instead
we have a universe a wash with mata
and barely two particles of antimatter
to rub together
so what exactly happened why did the
balance tip
in mata's favor a study of neutrinos in
japan
may just have found the answer
contradicting established beliefs that
matter and antimatter behave
in equal but opposite ways neutrinos
and anti-neutrinos have been found to be
doing
pretty much their own thing neutrinos
come in three flavors
electron muon and tau
if you're wondering why you've never
seen muon ice cream
that's because flavor in this case
basically just means
type yeah those damned poetic physicists
are at it again neutrinos are known to
randomly change flavors through the
process
of particle decay during a particle
physics experiment
called takai to kamioka or t2k
physicists tested the particle decay of
neutrinos
and anti-neutrinos theoretically mata
and antimatter are supposed to operate
in the same way
in a universe made up entirely of
antimatter
physics should work exactly the same as
one made up
of mata so the probability of decay of
the neutrinos
should have matched the probability of
decay
of the antineutrinos but
it didn't it's impressive enough that
the t2k scientists even discovered that
much
remember that neutrinos are impossible
to see
and travel freely through mata so as you
can imagine
they're pretty difficult to study like
the bat cave this project started
with a bloody big hole deep underground
the super cameo candy neutrino detector
in japan is located a kilometer below
the earth's surface
just deep enough that the sun's
radiation won't interfere with the
experiments
there the inside of a massive stainless
steel cylindrical tank
is covered in more than 11 000 sensors
that look like giant bubble wrap
wallpaper and filled with 50
000 liters of pure water it sounds like
the layer of some
science-obsessed bond villain but this
tank
isn't there to house laser sharks it's
designed to catch neutrinos
and anti-neutrinos fired from a particle
accelerator research complex 295
kilometers away
what physicists are watching out for are
not these particles themselves
but the reactions that sometimes occur
when a neutrino
or an antineutrino with an electron
imagine the smallest particle in
existence traveling at almost a speed of
light
smashing into one of the other smallest
particles in existence
and you get a sense of how difficult
this is to see
luckily despite being invisible the
neutrinos and their evil twin
counterparts
have other ways of showing themselves
namely
through cherenkov radiation that's the
glow emitted when a particle travels
faster than the speed of light
through a given medium kind of like a
sonic boom
but for light this cool blue glow
is created in the super cameo candy
detector
when a neutrino or anti-neutrino collide
with an electron
sending it ricocheting off faster than
the speed of light
in water by measuring these events
scientists are able to learn about the
flavor of neutrino involved
and where it came from which gives them
insights into the origins of stars
and even the big bang it's also possible
to determine the likelihood
that the neutrino or anti-neutrino in
question
changed flavor during its journey and as
it turns out
neutrinos appear to be rather more
likely to change flavor
than anti-neutrinos calling into
question
the long-held theory that mata and its
antimatter counterpart
have identical if opposite properties
if this is the case it could well
explain the asymmetry of matter
and antimatter we observe in the
universe
that's quite exciting but it took the
t2k experiment 10 years to study just
90 neutrinos and 15 anti-neutrinos
in what must have been the most boring
game of cosmic billiards ever
to help solve this problem the japanese
will soon be building
hyper cameo candy or hyper k
the largest neutrino detector in history
at almost five times the size of the
current version
it will cost about 600 million dollars
and will be dedicated to studying
neutrinos
and their antimatter opposites that's a
lot of money to study something
that goes straight through you i had a
curry like that once
and it only cost me five quid joining
hyper k
will be the deep underground neutrino
experiment
dune due to start in the united states
in 2025
and the jiangman underground neutrino
observatory
juno in china which is expected to come
online in 2021
but what do we hope to gain by building
all of these bloody great underground
swimming pools
whilst the results of the current t2k
experiments
are not statistically significant on
their own
having only studied a relatively small
number
of neutrino and anti-neutrino collisions
installations like hyper-k and june
are needed if we are to get a final
answer to that darn
mata anti-mata enigma if we can prove
once and for all that neutrinos and
anti-neutrinos
really do behave differently we open the
window to a new understanding of why the
universe is full of stuff
instead of a big empty place with a
couple of drunk photons
singing karaoke in the corner
thanks for watching thanks again to
blinkist for sponsoring this video
don't forget to check it out using the
link in the description